LAURA?
>> JOINING ME NOW, BEN SHAPIRO.
THE SPECIAL EPISODE TO
COMMEMORATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
D-DAY.
SO, FANTASTIC.
SO, BEN, WHICH ACTION IS MORE
TROUBLING HERE?
>> WHAT THE DAILY BEAST DID OR
THAT FACEBOOK JUST HANDED OVER
HIS NAME.
YOU HAVE TO EXPECT THE DAILY
BEAST TO BE THE DAILY BEAST.
YOU HAVE TO SAY NO MATTER IF
THEY WISH TO REMAIN ANONYMOUS OR
POSTED A YOUTUBE VIDEO.
THE FACT THAT FACEBOOK HANDED
OVER THE INFORMATION WAS TRULY
INCREDIBLE.
MY IMPRESSION IF YOU'RE POSTING
ANONYMOUSLY, IT'S NOT IN
FACEBOOK'S PURVIEW TO START
HANDING OUT THAT INFORMATION TO
MEDIA OUTLETS BUT I GUESS THAT
ISN'T TRUE
>> Laura: WHAT THIS IS, WE HAVE
TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS JUST ONE
MORE STEP TOWARD SILENCING OF
OPPOSING VOICES.
WE'LL FOCUS ON THE ASPECT OF
DOCKING SOMEONE, SOMEONE WHO
HADN'T SPENT ANY MONEY, A DAY
LABORER.
WE HAVEN'T CONFIRMED EVERY
DETAIL ABOUT HIM.
BUT THE GUY DOESN'T HAVE A LOT.
SO THEY MAKE HIM A SCAPEGOAT.
BUT THIS IS A WARNING SHOT, IS
IT NOT, BEN.
THEY TRY TO GO AFTER THIS
PROGRAM.
THEY GO AFTER OTHER PROGRAMS, GO
AFTER OTHER WEBSITES, DEMONIZE
THEM, TO SILENCE THEM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE BEATEN
IN THE RATINGS NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA LEFT ARE
INTENT ON DESTROYING ALL
OPPOSITION ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
SOME RANDOM GUY THAT DRIVES A
FORKLIFT AND POSTED A FUNNY
VIDEO OF NANCY PELOSI, IT SHOWS
HOW VILE AND ANGRY THE LEFT HAS
BECOME ABOUT TAKING OUT PEOPLE
WHO OPPOSE THEM IN ANY WAY.
I MEAN THIS, IS JUST THE
ULTIMATE EXAMPLE OF THAT.
BUT YOU MENTION, OBVIOUSLY,
EVERYBODY IN THE CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA HAVE BECOME A TARGET TO
THE LEFT AND THE LEFT WILL GO
OUT OF ITS WAY TO DESTROY
ANYBODY FOR ANY REASON SO LONG
AS THEY DO THIS.
CRAIG FERGUSON IN THE 2000thS
PUT UP A VIDEO OF GEORGE W. BUSH
CALLING HIM DRUNK.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT WAS A SILLY
VIDEO.
YOU HAVE A RANDOM FORKLIFT
DRIVER, ALL HELL POSTED I'M VERY
WELL LOOKING AND REVEALING THE
PERSONAL DETAILS ABOUT HER LIFE
BECAUSE SHE HAD THE TEMERITY TO
POST A PIECE OF NEWS THAT WASN'T
TRUE.
>> IF YOUR TARGET IS TRUMP OR
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT SOME OF HIS
POLICIES, THAT'S OKAY.
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING, SAY
ANYTHING.
FAKE HATE CRIMES, YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
I WANT TO PLAY THE DAILY BEAST,
NOAH SHAKMAN, DEFENDING THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE'S A PROFIT MOTIVE HERE.
THAT YOU CAN PUT UP A LOT OF
VIDEOS ON FACEBOOK, MAKE A QUICK
BUCK.
THIS GUY MADE $1,000.
BUT, YEAH, LOOK.
IT'S NOT -- IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LOT OF MONEY FOR HIM, I DON'T
THINK IT WAS PURE PROFIT MOTIVE,
FOR HIM, IT WAS IDEOLOGY, HE'S A
BIG TRUMP SUPPORTER.
YOU DON'T NEED SOME
SOPHISTICATED OPERATION IN ORDER
TO PUBLISH FAKE NEWS OR PUBLISH
A HOAX THAT WILL GRAB THE
COUNTRY'S ATTENTION.
>> THE DEFENDERS OF FREE
EXPRESSION, ALWAYS, ALWAYS
IMPRESSED, DON'T THEY, BEN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, I'M SO GLAD NOAH SHAKMAN
IS OUT THERE, PROTECTING US ALL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE ENEMY OF